another day another liar caught lying in
the Trump administration many of you
know that after forcing Attorney General
Jeff Sessions to resign Donald Trump
installed Matthew Whitaker as Acting
Attorney General we've already talked
about Whitaker's just horrible positions
on religion he previously said he
doesn't think anyone who's not a New
Testament Christian should be a judge in
the United States lots of other wacky
things he also previously indicated
exactly how he would try to stop the
robert muller investigation if given a
chance to do so and the Wall Street
Journal has now revealed that he is a
liar about his credentials Whittaker
claims that when he was playing football
at the University of Iowa he was an
academic all-american so called turns
out he wasn't the claim is on his law
firm biography it's on a resume he sent
in 2014 to a patent marketing firm where
he applied to work it's in the documents
that the Federal Trade Commission
released in November it was in a 2009
press release by the Department of
Justice and he claimed academic
all-american status when he applied to
be a judge in Iowa in 2010 The Wall
Street Journal contacted the University
of Iowa whose spokeswoman indicated they
have no record of Whitaker being an
academic all-american during his time
there the organization has their own
website academic all-america com they
show no sign of Whitaker being an
academic all-american
either so this is notable for a few
reasons one is it's another Trump
administration liar okay number two
being an academic all-american isn't
even that impressive you just need to be
an athlete with a 3.3 cumulative GPA
it's not like an insult to athletes or
anything I'm just saying it's a 3.3 GPA
and you're an athlete that that's all it
is it's not even an incredible
credential if you're applying to be a
judge or at a law firm and what we're
learning is that the guy Trump installed
to replace Jeff Sessions on an acting
basis is a scammer not only did he lie
about his academic background he worked
with a company that sold time travel
technology he lied on his resume he's
dying to interfere with the Trump
administration and in a sense this guy
is a perfect fit for the Trump
administration but he is
will fit for the country the real
problem isn't just that he's lying about
his academic credentials it's that the
guy advised the company that was a
literal scam sort of like Trump
University actually but more so even and
is currently under criminal
investigation the guy running the
Justice Department was advising a
company that is being criminally
investigated right now at some point
maybe we've already reached that point
do we start assuming everyone in Trump's
administration is a scammer or liar
until we prove otherwise whether the
phrase was I'll have the best people
around me or something like that and in
reality it's quite the opposite that's
going on and if you're gonna write to me
and say David this is a minor thing or
he was part of some other thing it was
an academic all-american but we found
the thing he was actually a part of or
whatever if it's not a big deal why is
he lying about it and as we've talked
about with Donald Trump it's
extraordinarily disconcerting when
people lie about insignificant things
because if they're lying about the
insignificant things what are the big
things that they're lying about I do
want to hear from you about this one of
today's sponsors is Skillshare which is
an amazing online learning community
that offers thousands of high quality
classes on almost any topic first 500
people who click the link under this
video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single
class offered by Skillshare they've got
classes on everything from design video
editing photography business technology
cooking meditation even classes on
personal productivity I know you'll be
able to find something on Skillshare
that fascinates you or even something
that will help you in your everyday life
classes are taught by real people who
care about what they're teaching I just
took a really great class on more
advanced video editing techniques the
david pakman show is giving you two
months of free access to every class
they offer when you click the link under
this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every
class on Skillshare for under 10 bucks a
month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up